will we be replaced with AI everybody's
using GPT but I always point out you
know to what extent could a computer
replicate the feeling of Happiness can a
computer ever potentially replicate what
the creative capability is of the
cerebrum of uh human beings do you think
it's possible if we ever had like a
computer that might process information
as the brain I think you would be able
to articulate that as long as you teach
them what is the feeling of happiness
and once you do that I think it will be
able to learn having like this sensation
of feeling or doing good based on the
previous sensation which is more or less
how the brain does as well